so it's got kid everything that's why
it's basically like watching every
stitch map so far this one is my
favorite I like having played the other
ones and beeper I've played all more
than this was my favorite extensions
lost hard zombies a year so any odds
keep her to humbly as I've said I've got
a Reaper so I don't want a wife I'm oh
do I just may lay all the things first
get bonus money if we do all men I ever
evolve what their they explode what I
when you kill them so pleasant blue
jumpy things a blue jumpy thing he's
down he's down what what I'm unloaded
into this bad boy Wow what's this thing
keep me warm I come to me come to me I'm
get him out I'm gonna man the turret on
a third IMF star not here just kids just
sweep the footage where I can get that
engine mount this ice is literate smell
third week are you and Ryan in this room
that went literally battling a giant
tentacle acini an electic sudden I'd be
up there seeming your leg dick Buster's
I'm dipping I'm different on different
self and either I've dog I'm putting
myself I put yo here we come dog nevah
key to want the toy I need help don't it
still may Ryan's just batter in this
Rhino I'm dead look at the soldier boy
say help Mike I've got no I'm I had zero
a motive yeah he's running at me oh my
goodness he's big boys what is going on
we're so close now I'm down I'm down
down to josé damaged wanted the one on
the flat six times who I'm going really
did you have looked at getting me out of
that corner whoa we so peak please
direct them don't let them hit me i'm
scared i'm dead i'm never been there
done that wait I'm coming I'm coming I'm
coming I'm coming I'm coming aren't I
got him oh my god is two big ones before
the same corner why why why would you do
that I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I'm go
down down down down yeah from or die now
might I quite enjoyed thinking
one that was fun battery decent yeah
dude another lie right so this is this
map is dead from the best exchange imap
I've ever played because I never played
one thorough enough to say